ما الذي يمكن أن تخبرنا به عن
هذا الهجوم أه أي شيء آخر عن
نوع السلاح الذي تم استخدامه وهل يمكنك
ضمان عدم مقتل أحد إلى جانب
الزواري ،
كل الأسئلة الجيدة بريانا ، لذا انظر إلى هذه
المهمة بالفعل على
مدار الأشهر الستة الماضية  لقد
كان نوعًا ما في وقت مبكر من هذا العام
عندما سمعت الرئيس يقول إن لدينا
مؤشرات على أن السيد الظواهري قد انتقل
إلى أفغانستان ، لذا فإن ما تمكنا من
القيام به هو تجميع بعض المعلومات الاستخبارية
على أساس تحركات عائلته
بصراحة تامة وبعد ذلك بمجرد أن
تعقبهم إلى كابول وتمكنا بعد ذلك
من تعقبه في جهوده
لجمع شملهم ، الأمر الذي أدى بعد ذلك إلى أسابيع إن
لم يكن عدة أشهر من التأكد من أن
لدينا الرجل المناسب الذي كان في
الواقع السيد زواري وأن هذا كان في  حقيقة
إقامتهم ثم بالطبع
تطوير نمط حياة أه
عاداته أه إذا ومتى خرج
كم مرة في أي أيام وكم من الوقت تم تضمين كل
هذا النوع من الأشياء فيه
ومرة ​​واحدة  كنا نعلم أن لدينا
نمطًا فعالًا من الحياة
والفرص التي يمكن اغتنامها ، فقد كان
حقًا في ذلك الوقت أن نجمع معًا
كيف ستغتنم هذه
الفرصة ومع ما
نستخدم في هذه الحالة مركبة جوية
بدون طيار بها صواريخ
بوضوح واثنين  من تلك الصواريخ أطلقت على
السيد الزواري بينما كان بالخارج في ذلك
الطابق الثالث أه الشرفة
أوضحها الرئيس عندما اتخذ
القرار
لكنه أراد التأكد من تفادي
وقوع إصابات بين المدنيين ونعلم أننا فعلنا ذلك
من سلسلة
أه المخابرات  أه ومصادر
أخرى متوفرة لدينا أه
استطعنا أن نتأكد بثقة عالية
أنه لم يصب
أو يصاب أو يسقط مدني ولا ضرر حقيقي
حتى للمنشأة غير
أضرار طفيفة أه من هذا أه من هذا
لقد رأينا هذه الضربة في الماضي حيث
كانت مشتعلة وأحرقوا
كل شيء من حولهم وهذا يبدو
مختلفًا.
في الاستهداف نفسه ، لكنني
أود أن أخبرك فقط أن
هذه الضربة تمت بطريقة دقيقة
للغاية ومدروسة
ومقيدة للغاية للقيام بالضبط
بما كان يُقصد به قتل رجل واحد ،
ما الذي تفعله طالبان في أعقاب
هذا الهجوم على
وجه التحديد  على الأرض مع
عائلة الزواري ،
كل ما نعرفه بريانا هو أنهم
ينقلون الأسرة ، ونعلم مرة أخرى
أنهم بالتأكيد نقلوا
الأسرة بعيدًا ، أصبح المنزل فارغًا الآن آه
لقد قاموا بالكثير من التنظيف
لقد كان بالتأكيد أن روايتهم
الأصلية عن هذا كانت خاطئة
أنه كان هجومًا صاروخيًا
ولم يصب أحد ، لذا فهم يحاولون إدارة
الدوران هنا قليلاً في
بيئة المعلومات لا يمكنني التحدث إلى
ماذا  يقوم قادة طالبان الآن بعمل
طويل الأمد فيما يتعلق بعلاقاتهم
مع الولايات المتحدة أو
بعلاقاتهم مع أه مع هذه
الشبكات الإرهابية لكننا أوضحنا
ما نتوقعه من سلوكهم في
المستقبل ، أليس كذلك؟  لقد تم
تأكيد
الحمض النووي لوفاته ، ليس لدينا تأكيد الحمض النووي
بريانا ، لن
نحصل على هذا التأكيد وبصراحة تامة
بريانا استنادًا إلى المصادر
والأساليب المتعددة التي جمعناها
من المعلومات لسنا بحاجة إليها تفعل ذلك
لدينا تأكيد مرئي لدينا
تأكيد مرئي ولكن
لدينا أيضًا تأكيد من خلال
مصادر وطرق أخرى